[Music]
this morning as we continue our look at
how children are coping with the
pandemic
we're hearing from high school students
in the washington d.c area
joaquin inohosa is a junior at northwest
high school
lyric j is a freshman at mckinley
technology high school lilly freeman
is a junior at walt whitman high school
and cedric
missouri is in his senior year at
benjamin banneker academic high school
jerika duncan recently met up with
author jason reynolds at banneker high
reynolds is the ambassador for young
people's literature for the library of
congress
and has been connecting with students
virtually throughout the pandemic
they spoke with the four students about
how covid
has transformed their lives by a show of
hands
how many of you all have been personally
impacted by the pandemic
lyric you've lost a loved one because of
the pandemic
yes i lost my aunt i'm sorry for your
loss how are you doing and if you could
talk about
that experience it was really hard for
me because i was very close to my
aunt first things first uh sorry lyric
for your loss
it's just been a very tough and enduring
time
not even to mention you know the social
aspect and
like i'm being a senior this year and
you know the year itself has just been
just been hard and i think for teenagers
especially
having our worlds closed off is not
something that
we can take for granted it's taken
everything away from us that used to
make life special
and joaquin i haven't seen anyone my age
since
march because my mom literally doesn't
let me go out the house like it all
hardly and so i lost that part and so
like
my mental health which i already
struggled with prior to that has just
been sort of magnified a lot
in quarantine you've been talking to
people in this age group is what they're
saying more of the same of what you've
been hearing for the last several months
absolutely i think it's an interesting
time to be a young person in america
because so many of them are in spaces
where they normally and naturally would
be having experiences that foster a
certain kind of growth
and the things that are necessary for
you to to transition
are the experiences that happen outside
of your home
and a lot of those experiences have been
cut short i want to turn now to
mental health joaquin you touched on it
a little bit early on when you talked
about sort of the challenges with
the pandemic how would you rate your
mental state throughout all of this
i i would say on a scale of one to ten
it's
usually every day on a good day it's
around maybe a six or
seven and then just normal days i'd say
it's around a three
two three really and it's not like i'm
having anything
directly happen to me like i'm not
having
just you know normal struggles or issues
it's just like a thing that i've just
sort of learned to
live with at this point thankfully my
parents are
they know of my struggles and um they've
tried to
you know get me help i
can completely relate you know i
struggle with clinical anxiety
and it's been a tough time you know and
i think it's important that young people
know that we're all different
and the way that our brains are working
is different and that it doesn't make
any of us small
it doesn't make any of us weak if you
are having a tough time right now
as a fellow person that struggled with
mental health how do you
overcome the adversity it's rough it can
be rough i've had some terrible
moments panic attacks things of that
nature and the one thing that's been
helpful for me first and foremost is the
acceptance of it
that i'm going to live the rest of my
life with this it's literally chemicals
in my brain that are different than the
next
persons and so i've learned over the
years
how to manage it before an episode
actually
happens i just want us to normalize it
it's okay
to not be okay it's okay to not be okay
listen i've done all the things i've
done i've done all those things with
anxiety
so there's nothing that can get in your
way i want to
turn a little bit here to something that
recently happened in the news what did
each of you all make of
what you saw happen at the capitol
the rioting that took place on january
6th
it was crazy to see just the initial
thought was
what had that been black people you know
i was shocked but then i wasn't because
i knew if it was african-americans doing
it it would have never went down like
that
it was just unacceptable and it
infuriated me on the inside it's sad
it's exhausting and i worry for our
generation but i definitely have hope
because i think that
collectively we all felt or most of us
felt
um the sense of outrage that is
necessary
for us to be able to enact the change
that ensures that the forces that
instigated the mob don't return in the
future
the new year is not slowing down the
unprecedented spread of coronavirus we
have to acknowledge that
hundreds of thousands of people have
died has there been any beauty that's
come out of
this sort of horrific moment like i got
to get
real close to my family i got more time
with my family
yeah i agree for me you know having that
time to
my mother and my sisters especially
being my last year you know i'll be
going off
to college this is a really important
time for me and i really appreciate
having the time to
spend with both of them i definitely
have gained a few hobbies i've
begun cooking for my family i like to
prepare meals
yeah not being able to you know go out
and go to restaurants and shops and
theaters
has forced me to really appreciate the
everyday beauties in life
and i think that might be um one of the
number one things i take away from the
pandemic whether that's
spending time with my family which is
just the most important thing or
looking out the window and seeing the
sun shining because those are really
the only things we have um i think the
pandemic has really helped me
be grateful for them
listen all of these students said it has
been a difficult time and expressed that
they had some problems with remote
learning
be it wi-fi connections or technical
issues but
the assignment if you will that jason
reynolds gave to the students is to
continue to talk about these things and
let people know
when they need help and the assignment
for parents and teachers he said
listen and for both groups give
ourselves grace
in this moment gail yeah that's such a
beautiful way to say that to rica i'm
also going to stick with your it's okay
not to be okay
we all need a reminder of that now and
again thanks to rica
always good to see you have a good
weekend